le maronnage est un phénomène défini par
la fuite des esclaves donc qui cherche à
fuir les conditions d'esclavage sur les
plantation euh c'est un sujet qui a été
étudié du point de vue historique à la
Réunion depuis les années 1970 et depuis
très récemment il commence à être étudié
sous un angle totalement nouveau qui est
l'angle archéologique donc il y avait
deux formes de maronnage tout d'abord le
petit maronnage qui définit des fuites
des fuites de petite durée souvent
quelques jours et puis il y a eu le
grand maronnage donc là des fuites de
très longue durée dans lesquels les
Maron s'organiser en bande et fuyer vers
l'intérieur de l'île vers des zones très
inaccessibles euh où il pouvait être
totalement dissimulé donc c'est cette
deuxième forme de maronnage qui va nous
intéresser pour pour le pour l'étude
archéologique puisque c'est celle-ci qui
va laisser des traces tangibles dans le
sol ou à la surface du sol l'intérêt de
l'archéologie du marinage à la Réunion
est de combler euh un certain nombre de
lacunes documentaires qu'on peut euh
voir dans les documents historiques donc
par par exemple on a euh très peu
d'informations sur le mode de vie de ces
escaves fugitifs dans dans les terres
intérieurs de de l'île on a des
informations sur la législation et
cetera sur les
peines soumises au au marron mais en
revanche on n pas du tout d'information
sur par exemple les les rites funéraires
ou leur le savoir-faire
architectural donc l'archéologie peut
apporter ce ces informations en en
donnant des preuves matérielles du
phénomène en démontrant l'existence du
Grand maronage à l'intérieur de la
Réunion et également en infirement ou
fment les hypothèses historiques donc
par exemple en 2011 et en 2012 on a
étudié un site qui s'appelle la vallée
secrète donc qui se situe à silaos dans
le siècle de silaos à plus de 2000 m
d'altitude donc c'est un site très
difficile d'accès qui a été choisi
justement pour son inaccessibilité et sa
totale dissimulation donc sur ce site on
a on a pu mettre en évidence deux
cabanes construites en pierces sèche
dans lesquels on a découvert des des
restes de foyers où euh les esclaves ont
euh cuit euh des des pétrelles de
barreaux donc c'est une espèce d'oiseau
endémique à la Réunion qui niche à une
période très particulière de l'année et
elle revient systématiquement à cet
endroit à la même période donc ce ce
qu'on a pu euh conclure c'est que les
esclaves avaient une connaissance accrue
du milieu naturel de la réunion des
ressources
disponibles dans durant l'année à quel
moment et qu'ils avaient l'intention de
revenir à cet endroit-là plusieurs fois
puisqu'ils sont construit de manière
pérenne les cabanes en pièces sèche et
non pas en matériaux
périssable donc évidemment l'archéologie
du maronage en est à ses début à la
Réunion il faudra beaucoup d'autres
recherches archéologiques pour définir
de manière plus approfondie l'ensemble
de des stratégies d'adaptation des
esclaves marrons à la
Réunion